good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we are just hours from
the 2018 midterm elections as you well
know and the noise levels are becoming
almost unbearable suddenly everybody's
shouting and posturing and trying to
scare and bully you into voting for this
or that candidate it's all very loud but
pause for a second and consider what you
are not hearing what is missing from
this cacophony for starters there is
hardly a word about Russia
remember that dastardly Vladimir Putin
and the collegian plot that hacked our
democracy whatever happened to that and
while we're at it how about Brett
Cavanaugh does that name ring a bell
what about his high school yearbook and
his purported teenage drinking problem
and all those gang rapes he's supposedly
committed what about those those are the
biggest stories in the world not so long
ago 24/7 on the other cable channels
those stories were going to define this
election they're going to define this
entire historical era everybody on
television told us that and now they are
just fading memories it turns out they
were sideshows the midterm elections
were never going to be fought over
Vladimir Putin or Brett Kavanaugh or
just about anything else we spend most
of our time talking about this election
like all elections was always going to
turn on issues that actually affect the
life of the country this year there are
three big issues immigration the economy
and nationalism the first is the most
obvious immigration determines who lives
next door to you it determines who works
in your office who chooses your leaders
there is nothing more fundamental in any
country than the question of citizenship
whatever Donald Trump doesn't know he
definitely knows this he's been talking
about immigration for three years now
for all of that time official Washington
has been trying to make him stop the way
Donald Trump has been conducting this
campaign attacking brown people making
up stories about you know possibly
George Soros funding caravans that are
still you know 800 miles away to try to
scare white voters in other words
shut up racist but Trump will not shut
up so they have changed tactics the new
line is the immigration doesn't really
matter the threat is hyped only dumb
people and bigots care about borders by
the way parties of both sides seem to
believe this Paul Ryan's office let it
be known to Politico this morning that
the Speaker of the House begged the
president last night to stop yammering
about this Caravan from Central America
and start talking about something
important like Paul Ryan its tax bill
that's pre-emptive blame-shifting
obviously if Republicans lose tomorrow
Paul Ryan can point the finger at Trump
rather than accept responsibility for
not funding the wall that voters said
they wanted but it's also a ludicrous
position to take because it's untrue
immigration does matter if for example
Arizona and Texas go to the Democrats
tomorrow immigration will be the reason
those were Republican states until the
population changed so no matter how much
you lie about it immigration is
inherently important and voters
understand that if you want people to
stop worrying about the border
maybe you should secure the border then
it won't be an issue but people are also
worried about other things that
Washington doesn't notice or think is
important here in Washington the economy
is synonymous with the stock market
markets have boomed for ten years their
entire cable channels devoted to
chronicling that boom
here in Washington the assumption is
that the economy must also be booming
but the truth is that after a decade of
stocks going higher the effects the
positive ones are still not very obvious
outside select zip codes on the coasts
in middle America many young people
understand that they will almost
certainly make less than their parents
made that is a reversal of the American
Dream they know they won't be able to
buy cars or houses they're not getting
married they're not having kids our
current economic system makes it more
difficult than ever for families to form
our middle class is becoming unable to
reproduce itself Washington should be
absolutely panicked about this it is the
most basic sign of failure their failure
but nobody in either party seems to care
their answer is just to import new
families from other countries so maybe
it's not so surprising that young people
say they like socialism because what we
have now is not working for them and
unless we fix it we may get actual
socialism which will be a disaster
and that leads to the third issue of
this election which is nationalism the
despite what you are hearing day in and
day out nationalism is not a racial
category it has nothing to do with race
or ethnicity nationalism is the belief
that leaders ought to put the interests
of their own countries above those of
other countries it's very
straightforward
the President himself declared himself a
nationalist the other night watch have a
word it sort of became old-fashioned
it's called a nationalist and I say
really we're not supposed to use that
word you know what I am I'm a
nationalist okay Trump's a nationalist
so in normal times the President of the
United States announcing that his main
goal is protecting the United States
would not qualify as news because until
about 10 minutes ago every leader of
every nation state throughout history
has been a nationalist almost by
definition Franklin Roosevelt was a
nationalist so was Abraham Lincoln so
was Mahatma Gandhi so is Nelson Mandela
nationalism has always been the rule and
why wouldn't it be and yet suddenly it's
an abomination nationalists use that
word we're gonna talk about that word
tonight it is a favorite of the
alt-right
and is loaded with nativists and racial
undertones and globalist well globalist
have been used as a slur of sorts
sometimes even against those in the
administration often with anti-semitic
overtones which just happened to make
the president come right out and embrace
nationalism openly
and claim that now what is happening
what are you trying to say as president
United States that you're a nationalist
Americans know what that means it's not
even a dog whistle anymore it's a bull
horn dumb people repeating the same
talking points so the message is
nationalism is now profanity the word
itself Twitter and Facebook will surely
be banning the term if they haven't
already but why what exactly is going on
here why are they so intent on stamping
out not just the concept the very word
it's simple
what you're watching is people
protecting their own prerogatives
globalization which is the opposite of
nationalism has caused an enormous
transfer of wealth from the American
middle-class to what we used to call the
third world to other countries American
factories closed but the jobs didn't go
away they just went to other countries
now some Americans got very rich from
this many others got poorer that's what
happened
rather than admit what actually happened
though the people who got richer are
trying to make the people who got poorer
shut up and stop complaining about it
a borderless world has been hugely
profitable for them that's why they
supported nationalism is their
kryptonite so they must stop it so they
scream racism and hope that nationalism
will go away will it go away probably
not because the core idea is appealing
to people all people in all countries
over all time people want leaders who
are above all on their side they always
have wanted that they always will want
that that's what we don't what we don't
know what's cool is what's gonna happen
in the elections tomorrow we won't even
guess nothing would surprise us but we
know what the real issues are because
it's obvious and we're gonna spend the
next hour talking about those issues